all right remember you can use the
coupon code fresh start all one word all
lowercase for the membership of your
choice at joinpackman.com we are mostly
funded by individual memberships at
joinedpakman.com
and in a little bit later a little bit
later today i am going to have a very
important story for you about why it is
that we are mostly funded
by individual memberships uh it is time
for
our first post-election hatred mail
quick reminder what is hatred mail take
a listen to this
take your mask and shove it now
let me tell you about my fake medical
condition
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate david pakman
because america and because
freedom okay this a week's hatred mail
needs no introduction other than to say
the hatreds are really really mad
about the election results take a listen
to this well
whatever you are if bitten does
win god help us and you for one thing
your cheap gas will go away next
if bitten has enough balls to stand for
the next attach
on my country next i hope you like
immigrants living in your backyard also
because they will be mr fake news
i love my country not like you bunch
petty waste wet behind ears muir
spreaders
and when war starts i'm sure your name
will be brought up to protect your
country
oh i forgot you're in the wrong country
i hope you like rice well i
said my peace which i am at peace
so have a nice life go ex-military
this is just um this
this is crazy and you know it's again
it's easy to just make fun of people for
the bad spelling and the bad grammar and
the incoherence and the conspiracy
theories and the lack of understanding
of politics and the lack of
understanding of math and the lack of
understanding of science and the lack of
understanding of psychology
and economics and finding okay you know
you get the picture but
i still maintain that even when somebody
talks to me about being
a mure spreader which i think they mean
manure spreader
we still saw nearly 72 million people
vote for donald trump
and if we really want to make
progressive change
happen in this country we either need to
um uh disabuse some of these folks
of their bad ideas or in some way engage
with them
and i am focused on pragmatic so uh
you know call that restrained when
someone is going completely crazy
attacking me but
i i'm focused on the future and that's
what we need to do now one thing you can
do to fight patriotism
is use the coupon code hatred 40 when
you get a membership at jointpakman.com
the coupon code hatred 40 saves you 40
percent
and when hatreds catch wind that the
coupon code has been used
they cry because they know they realize
their hatred mail is going nowhere
um that's h a t r i
f on your choice of membership at
joinpackman.com